[Applause]
[Music]
how are you I'm so good Kelly this is
the first time I've actually come to
your show and I know it was Zoom last
time it was virtual last time but I kind
of got emotional I walked in and I saw
all of these people on the walls that
you have actually interviewed you're on
like your fourth season it's crazy come
on no it's so funny you said that
because I had to leave the other day I
was where I work here in the studio as
well working on my album at time so at
night time I had to leave and I had to
go out this way and I never go down that
hallway and I went down the hallway and
I was like oh my God I mean I felt that
for you I remember when you first
started the first show came out four
seasons in yeah I know it's all right
um well good to see you your daughter
multi is one now she's one one 13 months
now that's exciting it's amazing how is
it y'all loving it yeah it's the oh my
gosh she's the most chill amazing baby
has the best personality laughing all
day super curious
um yeah but it's terrifying because she
bumps her head like five times a day she
only wants to play with why
constantly like that oh my God I
remember that I'm so glad that's not my
face right now yeah oh my gosh I mean
there's other ones does it get worse it
gets different it's like but it's
awesome I love my daughter was curious
like that too and it's I mean she's
totally gonna give me gray hair but
she's also like super bold like she's
and I love that from a young age like
even when she was like one I could tell
I was like oh she's gonna she's gonna
have a very good sense of who she is and
like very bold and brave and that's what
I you'll love that I feel like she's
Brave she knows exactly what she wants
yeah but it's also going to give you
gray hair yeah this is me too I think
it's starting Nick said that she um he
sings to her right yes I think that's so
adorable like even whenever like she was
in the womb right like that's adorable
what kind of music what Tunes when we
were in I mean for those who don't know
um we had a really rough Journey with
multi and she was in the NICU for about
110 days
um and pretty much the whole third
trimester and Nick used to go in with
his guitar and I mean sing to her I
played my audiobook you know
or movies I couldn't compete I was like
not like that yes you can it's Mama's
voice yeah but I mean I did she's the
only fan of my voice she like loves when
I sing the only person
so wait you and Nick have a ritual that
I didn't know about so it's called show
and tell this is pretty cute it kind of
was in a ritual it just happened because
of necessity um we both didn't know very
much about each other's careers I mean I
know of the Jonas Brothers but you know
it's a different generation yeah I was
like I didn't really grow up with the
music and yes I didn't know the history
even though him and I both have 22-year
careers because he started his at seven
yeah
um but so we started showing each other
each other's work like we would sit and
be like oh you know this was the most
traumatic day on set for me on my first
movie and he was like oh this was my
most traumatic show and we'd kind of
show each other uh careers or highlights
from our careers and talk about what we
were really feeling that time and it's
just become this thing that we do
whenever we're by ourselves at home yeah
go down the rabbit hole because y'all
met and y'all got together pretty
quickly right yeah so it's kind of cool
you get to know each other like still
yeah I mean we knew each other for about
two years yeah but we didn't like really
date we were both in other things
like doing like other jobs and stuff
yeah no other relationships
[Laughter]
for sure
miss them though like to show like I
don't know I just think it's a very cute
way to like get to know your significant
other that you think you know everything
about but they weren't there for that
whole they learned right and I think
it's such a fun thing to especially both
of us have had such public careers we've
both grown up in our own way I love that
you both didn't know each other's
careers I know it's so crazy that's kind
of cool I think so too yeah it's really
fun like you know you're there for the
right reason we show each other our
embarrassing moments because you know
that's your person and you're safe with
them yeah and it's funny my bad
performances and be able to laugh at it
yeah oh me too
um well you turned 40 this past year we
always forget we're the same age so do
you do you feel different
once I hit 40 I feel like I like life a
lot better the more I mature I like life
but like I think it's just better it's
easier you're wiser but like um also
like things hurt yeah it didn't hurt or
you can't bounce back as quickly oh
definitely not just the one thing that
happened after 40 was I like to incubate
a lot more I like spending time with
myself my family my priorities have
suddenly become really clear the I don't
sweat the little stuff
um but also your metabolism takes a big
hit yeah you're like oh I see that
sandwich for the next week yeah no or
that pizza and I love food I live for
food me too you know but my job is not
yeah like doesn't like the fact that I
love food as much as I do so that
changes your relationship with your body
changes
um I used to work a lot I still do I
work a lot I love my job I feel very me
too I like working I love working I love
my job but you know you get tired yeah
you want to go home and like I'm really
looking forward to napping after the
show yeah and that would be nice and a
nap I mean by like sleep like
yeah I don't know why I said nap really
I mean usually I think because I don't
get a full night's rest and I need it
but like no I just mean a full night's
rest I'm very excited about that yeah to
be able to sleep eight eight hours oh
yeah if you get it it's well you have a
one-year-old you might not get this card
it's hard we are back Priyanka Chopra
Jonas yeah give it up
again so why did you want to be a part
of it it's just first of all that Celine
Dion's acting debut I know that's
incredible crazy for the rest of time I
never knew she'd do it yeah that's
incredible I just can't believe she
hasn't done it I I guess like you would
either yeah she's so funny very
passionate she's super passionate and
she came in like such a professional on
this movie she helped me and Sam's
character find love and we have original
music from Celine which we haven't had
for a really long time yeah and she's
grappling with some health stuff so I'm
just really excited to be able to you
know see her and have her fans see her
again in the movie yeah so that was a
big reason but also this movie is a
remake of a German film and it's just so
sweet I love a great rom-com me too I
love like you know what makes it don't
make enough smile yeah we don't yeah and
I love that moment of being able to go
into theater getting like a bag of
popcorn and sitting and watching a movie
that makes you feel hopeful yeah happy
and you find love again
love again yeah some of us don't
yeah Nick is also in the movie I didn't
know that so was he just there with you
and then y'all are just like hey come do
this okay I love this I know I was
moving to London This Is 2020 and it was
like during like in the middle of course
yeah and um Nick was like no I'm gonna
come to London with you make sure you're
settled and then come back so he was
kind of there with me to support yeah
and I was filming and the producers were
like well Nick's here do you mind can we
do you think we could uh and I was
actually really grateful that it was
that they wanted to ask him yeah because
the scene as it was written is a bad
date yeah and it's slow kiss slow
slobbery kissing
with an actor
and it was written
written and I had to do it with a
stranger like a random person slobbering
slowly on my phone I've had to do that
in a music video and I have a thing with
saliva it was a hard day I don't do that
that'd be my traumatic figure I'd show
my significant other
you can't do that so I'm so grateful
that Nick first of all
and second of all that it was my husband
that did it
exactly like so funny for everybody that
little nugget in the movie of like
you're like not interested in your
husband it's funny
um so speaking of movies though you and
I are now the only people with our own
flavors of of Rob's backstage popcorn
this is mine this is yours I want to try
yours you haven't tried it no I haven't
been able to try it oh I I asked you I
think
um
yeah
yours too wow that was really loud it
was like
I was like I'm used to being on TV guys
I promise look at that barbecue it's
called Numb by Night Mumbai nights it's
got Mumbai nights because it's so yummy
um because it reminds me of the Mumbai
heat Mumbai is very humid and this has
like a kick to it I love it Indian spice
blend I use some of my favorite spices
like turmeric and girl this is good
right I love turmeric and like cumin and
garlic and onion we're gonna keep eating
keep eating it's great you keep talking
oh you're really good you have a new
series too it's called Citadel yes I do
I love this I'm excited about this what
is it about it's on Amazon Prime and it
is a spy show it's out there now you
guys should check it out it's a really
great spy show it's got Richard Madden
Stanley Tucci me
um an amazing cost of people but it's
six episodes and it's
um a really sick show there's never been
anything at the scale of like action
stunts and of the production value of
the show but at the same time it has
real heart with characters like my
character and Richard's character have
drama we have history plus we have to
save the world and they have to do it
together I'm into all that it's so good
because of all of that is the action
hard for you like the scenes like
actually scenes are I feel like
you're always
in someone else I like that I have done
a lot of my stunts my whole life but
I've I've also learned to do that
because I mean I started with you know
smaller Bollywood movies and we never
had a stunt double that was awesome oh
gosh they're gonna kill me for that clip
oh I'm like wait which oh okay that's me
pole vaulting over a horse
it didn't even make it and you pole
vaulted over a horse yeah a stallion
yeah that's a big horse I mean I was
rigged but yeah still pole vaulting over
still looks so cool it looked amazing to
be in the in the show it lives on my on
my phone I watch it every couple of days
just to remind myself I remind myself
that I'm capable of that but I love I
love stuns and I love I trust my body a
lot
um I've had a lot of experience doing it
but you know working with the Russo
Brothers they have such an amazing stunt
team like look at all the stuff they've
done with
um the Marvel stuff and you know they
their stunt team taught us a lot we
trained it was a year and a half of
training and wow being prepared and
working on your body and learning like
there's so much so many stunts in this
but it makes you feel like such a sense
of achievement when you watch the show
and you're like wow like 80s that was me
yeah and and I did a great job yeah it
was it was challenging but it was
gratifying too yeah so
I actually have equal
your milk co-star yeah I love that did
you you had to fight hard for that
because I know in many of actresses that
have tried to do this and it doesn't
always work that's incredible it doesn't
usually work and they're like weird
um excuses for it that you know you're
not actually co-leads or you're not as
accomplished or but in this you can't
hear that enough yeah yeah I know you
know because the male actor has
accomplished a lot more or like there's
always some sort of debate but I've had
a 22 year career I've worked with many
many male co-actors around the world
um I have done many as co-leads which is
what the show was so my contract was
actually done and I remember my agents
at UTA love you guys
um went in and said you know you're a
co-lead on the show you should have most
favorite Nation with Richard and I was
like oh really I mean I guess I should
but like that's not gonna you know yeah
yeah I'm jaded enough to be like well
that's not gonna happen I'll take
whatever I'll get yeah um and they were
like no let us go back and have that
conversation with the studio yeah yeah
they went back to Amazon Studios and
they really didn't have any pushback
they were like you're right they're
co-leads they should have most favorite
Nations and they came back and they were
like well you have the same parody and
the same pay and I was like wait what
happened and they were like yeah I did
so there are some people that'll do that
that's amazing
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]